hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to talk about the two most
powerful anti-cancer foods on planet
Earth
okay and they're both there full
spectrum of like most the cancers
there's a lot of things that can
actually cure cancer or kill cancer or
prevent cancer but this is encompasses
like the most different types of cancer
and the most organs okay this first one
can kill cancer within 30 minutes get
certain cancer cells within 30 minutes
okay after consuming it and there's no
side effects
it's called garlic garlic is well
researched I mean it is amazing for your
immune system it's good for heart
cholesterol blood sugars but
specifically it's the top of on the food
chain as far as anti-cancer okay now
this next one is not quite as powerful
but it's number two one ounce of this
stuff is equivalent to one and a half
pounds of broccoli and you know broccoli
is very anti-cancer and it's called
broccoli sprouts now what are broccoli
sprouts they're baby little broccoli
plants okay like four days old
apparently at right around that period
of time it releases the most
phytonutrients which are anti-cancer
properties and other health benefitting
factors and even Hopkins University try
to get the patents on certain broccoli
sprouts because they saw the benefits of
course they got sued in the Supreme
Court went to battle and they lost it to
the sprout manufacturing companies or
the farmers which is a good thing
because you can't patent a living thing
but anyway broccoli sprouts is
incredibly powerful for cancer
prevention and also reverting cancer and
what you can do is put on your salad you
can actually consume it in concentrate
pills and powders
but I like to make my own but it's these
are the two most powerful anti-cancer
and if I've personally had cancer I
would be consuming these if I was at
risk I would consuming these or just in
general you should be consuming these
two foods thanks for watching hey guys
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it please click the share
button below and I will see you in the
next video